there is some debate over whether I was  gonna wear a dress or Muppet dude I'm so  all about pants life fashion definitely  on point for Mom Naomi Watts good night  - Maggie Q rockin highlights Reem Acra  and fiance Dylan McDermott on her arm  you guys are like a ridiculously keep up  a town even birthday boy Ansel Elgort  got rave reviews fabulist red bean happy  birthday at the after party mister now  22 busted a move on a table co-star  shailene woodley put on jeans for some  dirty dancing inside and we were warned  that this crew can throw down  hit me crazy ladies and gentlemen while  the drinks are free so I'll be buying  Ansel a lot of free shots later tonight